what do you think the job and labor
market will look like in 20 years and
how can people prepare
well i i mentioned in the first
interview that the industrial revolution
sort of brought people together because
a minimum efficient scale
to uh do something especially with a
factory was very large so you need to
have a hierarchy you need to have people
working for each other and working
together now i think information
technology is lowering the communication
cost lowering transaction costs and
people can be intermediate or even
disintermediated by computers and work
through computers so the you know a not
so great example is an uber driver who
would be getting orders through the um
through a phone
but a better example a more hopeful
example might be
independent contractors who are using
twitter and
online sources to find jobs or you know
angel list we have tons of startup jobs
or there are places like pick crew or
gigster where you can go
get part-time jobs elance craigslist
odesk etc
so i think that gig economy is going to
be much more of the future and it can
actually be a very positive development
for example if you are a great
journalist today if you're a world-class
journalist you take great photographs
you report great news you don't really
need to go work for the new york times
if you are willing to start your spare
time with a blog with twitter you can
build an independent brand and although
you start off making no money early on
kind of near the end of the curve when
you're a youtube star or a blog or a
very popular blogger you can literally
be charging people for access to your
blog and you can be making a very good
and very independent living where you're
getting paid for books and newsletters
and working from wherever you want so i
think the best way to prepare for the
future 20 years is find something you
love to do so you have a shot at being
one of the best people in the world at
it
build an independent brand around it
with your name not with a company's name
or with other people's names around it
try to make it creative work so you'll
stay interesting you stay ahead of the
game anything that's not creative
society can replicate and then not pay
you full value over time so it's better
to always solve new problems and do new
things and get comfortable
with working in a boom bust fashion
where a couple of weeks at a time you
may have a lot of work and then a couple
of weeks at a time you're on vacation so
i think that's kind of where the future
is headed it'll be
gradual
and then it'll be sudden
but the the best way to prepare is to
just not give up your independence in
the first place
if you look at the greatest competitors
in the world greatest physical athletes
marcelo garcia who's a who i trained
with for many years so i own a judicial
school within the city um
if you he's probably the greatest
grappler to ever live and if you watch
marcelo in a world championship
he would be sleeping literally minutes
before
um
a moon jal's semi-final final sleeping
and but you've never seen anyone turn on
more intensely and if you look at great
fighters people think fighters are like
jacked and intense but they're not like
they're actually very relaxed the
greatest fighters are super relaxed when
they're not fighting but when they're in
the battle you wouldn't believe the
intensity and even to deconstruct that
further if you watch a great for example
boxer
the relaxation before a strike is
delivered is incredible so does the
undulation like most people in
high stress decision making industries
are always operating at this kind of
simmering six
or four
as opposed to the undulation between
just deep relaxation and being out of
ten and being at a ten is like millions
of times better than being at a six it's
not
it's just in that different universe
same same as being all in on a
discipline is millions of times more
intense than being
you know 98 or 99 let alone you know i
could take it or leave it yeah and
just having observed you observed
marcelo
certainly heard stories about say floyd
mayweather before gigantic fights and
i heard a friend of mine who knows him
said he walked into his dressing room
after floyd was like yeah sure come on
in he's like i don't want to interrupt
you
you must be prepping and he's like no
i'm either ready or i'm not and he was
just sitting down watching some tv
that
it's
it's
in a way
your ability to avoid the simmering six
directly affects your ability to then
ratchet up to turn on to the 99 or the
100 right if you're always at a
simmering six
you're just at 50 battery
right all the time 100 and 50 percent
intensity and you cannot you have no
idea what your tent is
[Music]
[Music]
you